[Music]
in not mine news that's not my submitted
by JK where have you been
wait a minute here maybe JK films may be
around we're always here notifications
on dude yeah yeah use that bail a man
can't get any work done because someone
keeps ordering pizzas on his behalf you
can't get the words he's like oh I guess
I'll have to eat pizza again that's my
picture that's awesome
oh man you know how we got some pizza
huh I didn't know this but we could
actually get more tomato sauce oh we can
yeah during our writers retreat and then
we got pizza like the week before that
no my dad yeah I'm like that pizza
really sucks now and I just ordered the
stock Pizza Hut whatever during the
retreat was good
no and you gotta get like the flavoring
on the crust
oh good never mind even know yeah well
I'm gonna call back the Domino's or
Little Caesars but like up there with
pizza dominoes to me it's like pizza
I still Caesars at Domino's and Pizza
Hut is like probably are you out of your
mean Little Caesars of five $5 Pizza
ready Pizza should be very damn I have
to try it again because I didn't like
dominos but then they changed your
recipe Domino's is the [ __ ] now their
family gets those Caesars like every
week no one whatever your brother has
like a get together with the moon
bouncing he always has a pile Little
Caesars almost eaten is really only good
sandwiches what are you talking about
really gets a little caesars alright
what kind of sandwiches subway Walmart
Walmart sandwiches like the catering
what is it though it's just a subway
sandwich oh yeah
did you guys ever get those big Subway
sandwiches for parties yeah that goes
all the way across the table the [ __ ]
except now it's bad cuz that used to be
Subway's thing yeah and some ways
terrible man it's bad and they're all
like somebody's trying to figure out
what can we do to increase company like
it's a gear [ __ ] sucks that's yeah make
it stop tasting like [ __ ] like yoga mat
[ __ ] ingredients they found out the
chicken has like other like rubber in
there something like like illiterate
Robert no no no but like something that
means the chicken to erase some of my
energy not see exactly yeah you can use
it as a sponge or some tempur-pedic
chicken yes this lawyer he's from
Germany his name is Guido it's like my
cousin Vinnie yeah
Guido Lawrence Oh what do you want yeah
he has filed a complaint with the police
because someone keeps sending him pizzas
his workplace and so over the past two
and a half weeks he has received over a
hundred pizza oh my don't never ordered
would you that's a good thing he's not
getting charged so whoever sending all
this in like they're the ones that are
paying all right even so they're saying
like well the ones that are really
losing here are the pizza the people
delivering the pizza because then they
end up making the food no one ends up
eating it but no one's paying but they
are saying that they they are paying for
it but then if it comes back where
there's like a credit card fraud or
something and are the is this the same
pizza establishment that it can't get
why's that
Guido's not ordering the pizza and they
keep delivering it anyway welcome all
pizzas open so you have to call every
pizza place in the whole city and be
like if you get a delivery for me don't
bring it but then what if he wants
babies like it's Friday I want pizza not
touch me
it's work please he just has to have his
neighbor pick up the pizza he found he's
figured it out man I was worried for if
you want to if you really want a pizza
party what were you gonna do doesn't
have any angry clients or any rivals so
he doesn't
who could possibly be doing this to him
but morning but like he he's saying like
there must be some sort of weird virus
or something because one morning between
nine twenty and 947 he got 15 Pizza
pre-order emails he's saying like no one
can order pizza that fast
well the night wait can I feel you can
order pizza pretty fast wait so it's all
online then so yeah so he's getting the
the email confirmations it's his phone
number attached to the order and his
address and his name so it's just a
mysterious Pizza prank has he ever been
like I don't think probably I don't know
you should just like take them all and
then have like a sign outside like
homeless come here for free food there
you go and then that'll serve that what
if he takes a minute to pay for them
yeah I don't think so someone's already
paying for it to be delivered right or
no yeah if it's online someone probably
paid for it yeah yeah I mean well
they're saying the real question is what
type of pizza is it supreme is it
[ __ ] yeah pineapple is everyone your
chit is he one of those people who's
like I don't want cheese I know they're
boring I'm [ __ ] lactose like a
[ __ ]
and I'm allergic to milk in three
different ways but I'm not lactose
always so confusing like you're like no
constant so confuse though no it's not
dates back a while it gives me eggs amah
that's my worst one but you know what's
crazy I think I've been cured man we
[ __ ] eat that [ __ ] no eczema I'm
gonna [ __ ] was a big ass line that you
just did like an extra huge lie I don't
know because it's been the first year of
my whole entire life where I don't get
eczema baby reverse you know how they
say that guys people get older sometimes
they develop lactose-intolerant
but then maybe for you it's the opposite
I think it's like the more you eat it
the more your body will start creating
the enzymes you'll break it down yeah
what the opposite happened to you I
stopped
because I saw I lived with you and you
don't drink any milk or products so now
my body can't handle it anymore
oh yes that's funny
maybe you have to slowly like ease back
into now Oh eat ice cream five makes me
want to clear my throat I do want pizza
though mm-hmm oh yeah you guys can come
over somewhere you just got a stack of
them in your freezer I got a stack of
coupon in my wallet and so you can go to
a supermarket to get it yeah I wanna we
doing this weekend this weekend for
Oscars the Oscar we're gonna do it all
Oscar what's Oscar okay I never watch
Oscar so how come they named admission
and invite you guys how come they name
the Oscars after a Mexican child I never
thought of that it's the only children
that are named Oscar I'm in a white
Oscar oh really yeah I feel like Oscar
is an old white name and then it turns
yeah maybe
why anyway back to the jacket was the
name of someone's uncle I read the story
behind it so just call the Academy
Awards
but then the statue look like some of
the staffs uncle Oscar you just call it
the Oscars but it's actually called
Academy lot I've not watched a single
Oscar nominated movie this year this is
like the first year I haven't watched
any of them yet but they all just sounds
so boring do the titles are terrible the
phantom thread that
billboards outside of Missouri but like
the titles of this place
get the title to the movies are really
okay
but anyway back to this guy here he's
he's been receiving so much food and in
there while she get jumped I don't know
anyone that complains about pizza if
you're getting free pizza deliver to
your door and you're complaining about
his work that's like every 10 minutes
though yeah
I bet you he has to pay for it you can
sit there's a setting were you it's like
you deliver the goods about paper - yep
there is yep so I'll bet you anything
it's that
yeah well otherwise my dude would I
would I have your back yeah because I
would just get a custom pizza door
because there's so many pizzas coming in
and the people just put it into the door
and I would have like some sort of
device that would just take all the
pizzas and the food because now he's
getting greedy get a pizza Secord's
device yeah I understand I'm like
currywurst Oh what kind of troll is that
that's like the weirdest [ __ ] you're
really just trolling the delivery guys
this is a GrubHub glitch or something in
the back no it's an AI bully it's the
first AI boy there you go
they're good at it to send you free
pizza you're tired pizza I mean this
guy's you otherwise terrified now no I
mean they're also saying that so the
cops here they're saying that they're
gonna be treating this as a stalking
case because it doesn't qualify as fraud
since the potential offender doesn't
have any financial gain out of that so
how does this [ __ ] make the news no is
it like is this guy it was like man I
can't get any work done cuz all I get
all these pizzas delivered me constantly
and I'm just interrupted by pizza and
then he's like he's like oh okay I got
I'm done with this for now he's like I'm
gonna call the news and tell him about
my story and they're so hungry for
stories I like your story better thank
you right yeah usually he's like a
procrastinator yeah geez every excuse
yeah yeah I want to do that I want the
News's phone number I want some I want
to talk about something like interesting
don't pick up man then they're down for
whatever
hey news just the other day I was
climbing on my apartment roof and I
noticed that is boring you know no you
got to do something it's gonna be like
something like uh I was climbing on my
roof and then I found a loose tile and I
picked it up and then I found this old
hundred-year-old calling yeah
oh yeah huh you mean the a
hundred-year-old coin found in a ten
year old building right yeah catchy yeah
clickbait t see I said I gotta learn
quick gotta learn the hooks man you
gotta hook them in you know k delivery
hey uh hi news yeah I stopped pooping I
know I got stopped pooping how many days
has it been sir like it's been eight
days in like oh and that's like oh
here's the guy who stopped pooping you
have to read the rest of the story yeah
and then twelve websites I'll do the
same story on sanity that's right you
even rewrite the rewrite the thing at
all it's just copy verbatim copy paste
yeah that's amazing
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you